when the g20 leaders first met in
November of 2008 at the first summit in
Washington they said something like this
mayor underlying factors to the current
situation and the current situation was
a major crisis where among others
inconsistent and insufficiently
coordinated macroeconomic policies
inadequate structural reforms which led
to unsustainable global economic
outcomes these developments together
contributed to excesses and ultimately
resulted in severe market disruption
then they had a great summit in london
in april of oh nine and they met for the
third time in pixel in September of old
nine and at peaks were they announced a
framework for a strong sustainable and
balanced growth where they committed
their governments to work together to
ensure and I want to underline this that
fiscal monetary trade and structural
policies are collectively consistent
they also permitted to collectively
undertake macro-prudential and
regulatory policies to help prevent
credit and asset cycles from becoming
forces of destabilization furthermore
they committed to have robust policy
recommendations ready for an executable
agreement by the November 2010 korea
summit well if one wants to be benign
and charitable given what I you read it
will be very hard to blame the g20 for a
lack of a right diagnosis and Anna
scarcity of good intentions I think they
had a good diagnosis and they have very
good intentions however in order to
solve complex problems much
more than good intentions is needed the
fact is that as we gather here today on
the one hand we couldn't declare the 08
09 crisis over it's not over and given
event during this summer and during the
fall it is not our landish to believe
that there is a significant probability
that the world may be at risk of dipping
again into a global crisis and I think
particularly after the events of today
this holds true of course we are where
we are because domestic policies in each
of the relevant economies or I should
say domestic political systems have
failed to implement and deliver the
actions warranted but their own national
interests so there is a failure of
domestic policies but I think and I
submit to you that this failure also
obeys to the fact that the countries at
the g20 particularly the key ones having
properly adopted and executed the kind
of international coordination and
cooperation that they committed to the
liver at least during the first three
summits but in any case we are where we
are I must say that personally I have
always been a supporter of the idea of a
g20 well before the g20 at the leaders
level was adopted in various documents
statements and studies I express that
that was necessary so in a way my
criticism is directed to the idea that
we need something like the g20 but my
skepticism really is addressed to the
fact that the g20 which of course has a
problems of legitimacy in its origin
because it's a group of self-appointed
countries to steer the global economy
could have legitimacy stemming from the
delivery of the actions needed to
overcome and the economic and financial
crisis and here we are three years after
and the delivery is not there and
therefore the g20 can have a double
problem of legitimacy legitimacy of
origin and legitimacy legitimacy fail
legitimacy of execution and this I think
is a very bad news for the work because
this is one more example in which what
some people call global economic
governance which is not the same as
global economic government is falling
behind the process of global integration
through which we have done particularly
over the last decades which evidently
has had a lot of benefit for humanity at
large but we also knew that it also has
significant downsides and if you want to
minimize those downsides then you must
be willing to adopt a reasonable degree
of global economic governance because if
you don't have that then we can be in
deep trouble as present circumstances
clearly show so that is the general
framework although the specifics are
much more entertaining
and i would say depressing to say the
least and this is not really black humor
i think we are really at a severe risk
to be in a very difficult almost a
dramatic economic situation again and
this happens when we must recognize that
the political and economic capital that
governments have to confront crisis of
this magnitude has been diminished
significantly because it has been in the
last three years confronting and dealing
with a very difficult situation so it's
almost ironic that this new g20 is
summit that will be taking place in a
couple of days income france takes place
in conditions of uncertainty of almost
cows even more severe than conditions
that prevailed at the time of the first
summit in november of 2008 because after
all by the time of the summit at least
central banks had been reasonably
coordinated finance ministers had taken
some steps the US authorities were in
the process of controlling the financial
crisis to some degree in this country
and many actions have been taken so in a
way leaders could get there to reason in
a more calm way with a visa situation in
September of 08 and today they don't
have that privilege they have had formal
preparations towards the summit and let
me tell you something in my opinion
whatever they prepared has to be put in
the garbage circumstances are so
different relative to their preparation
for this summit and i am not i'm not
sure what they are
really going to talk about and how they
are going to face up to come out and say
here we have guidance solution up a plan
as we promised three years ago and two
years ago that we will have and finally
we have it and the world can have some
peace of mind influent of economic
events unfortunately I cannot predict
that that will happen and probably we
will have a rather difficult if not
cumbersome album out of the g20 so to
discuss those and other issues we have
now really an a fantastic panel with
three outstanding individuals who have
dedicated a lot of study Talon to
analyze issues like the ones that
concern us this afternoon we have of
course our very own steep Roach who
after a long career as a chief economies
of a large financial institution and has
come to our University as a senior
fellow at the Jackson Institute for
Global Affairs some of his students are
here I know and most people know about
how sharp steep has been well before the
crisis warning people about what was
cooking and during the crisis and he has
had enormous contributions for our
understanding of the situation we have a
Venice deal who is from the his director
of international economics at the
Council of Foreign Relations but if you
look his books in addition to his
present work and the things that he has
written about and he is incredibly
powerful insight into the workings of
the global financial system of the
global economy you will agree with me
there is really a privilege to have you
here Ben and then we have also a great
acquaintance of us because we got the
owner of having a carmen reinhart as a
distinguished visiting fellow of our
Center and that is probably the top of
your career time I'm just easy but
Carmen is it is incredible because she
very few people can say that they have
had a distinguished career in academia a
distinguished career in an international
organization are now being very quickly
becoming the face a one it not the most
prestigious economics think tank in the
world the Peterson Institute for
International Economics and carmen has
been there I would say just for a few
months and every time I look for Carmen
she's doing something of course on
behalf of her cell but also on behalf of
the Institute and we are so privileged
to to help you here again because the
work you have done Carmen yourself and
with your husband and we can drove off
in the now famous book of this time is
different it's so powerful a
contribution to understand the problem
we are in and I would say it's all
relevant to derive some pertinent policy
conclusion and therefore is also great
to have you here so with that
introduction why don't we ask carmen to
make some opening remark what i could do
is to ask or participants to give some
ten minutes of opening remarks then we
may have some discussion among ourselves
and this is a house of debate so we will
not be shy but on any debate and then we
can have some interchange with our great
audience so Carmen please well thank you
it's a pleasure to boops its own yeah
okay it's a pleasure to be back here I
very much enjoyed my
I visit here last year what I'd like to
do in those two minutes is puts various
themes on the table that draw on my work
on financial crises I'm going to start
by saying I really I don't envy the g20
I will start out by saying that it if
the g20 had the diagnosis correct in
2009 if they had the set of solutions in
2009 I would venture to say would not
have made a difference because the
characteristic feature that we're going
through in both sides of the Atlantic it
is more extreme in Europe right now but
I to reiterate it is on both sides of
the Atlantic in the US as well is a
massive form of denial we we have gone
let me just briefly start out and this
is some of the work that I've done with
Ken Rogoff Ken Rogoff and I recently
wrote a paper called from financial
crash to debt crisis the basic point of
that paper is that these processes start
out with a lot of private borrowing big
surges in private debt banks borrow
households borrow debts get out of hand
during that boom period in which debts
are being piled up asset prices tend to
do very well in fact they tend to boom
the economy does well and everybody's a
genius however during that boom period
bad loans are made and ultimately the
result is a financial crisis that's
stage one we're past that okay now
that's stage one financial crisis morphs
into a fiscal crisis which is where
we're at revenues as the financial
crisis deepens recessions and we've
written about this with with both
Vincent my husband Vincent Reinhart and
we can
we did a paper for Jackson Hole last
year Vincent and I called after the fall
which basically makes a point look post
crises decades are subpar in terms of
growth weaker growth higher unemployment
week or asset prices okay uh the
recession's are deeper longer lasting no
surprise that government finances
deteriorate further more the government
takes on a lot of the debt that was
previously private that becomes public
debt this was true in the United States
in the form of Fannie and Freddie Fannie
and Freddie the two mortgage giants were
part of the financial sector debt
private financial sector in 2010 they
become part of the public sector debt
that added about 25 percentage points to
the public debt in the US why am i
bringing this up I'm bringing this up
because what is next okay in this
sequence so the financial crisis moved
to a fiscal crisis that's where we are
in in in Europe we're having what we
call debt with drama in which solvency
questions you know abound and this is
not just for greece and in the US uh the
the crisis is more latent but it is a
fiscal crisis nonetheless in the making
um so I mentioned the word denial in in
Europe the denial has been a biblical
proportions I mean you know we've been
calling a solvency crisis a liquidity
crisis for two and a half years and the
turmoil that we are also seeing in this
day is in part a byproduct of that
denial so if you really recognize that
you don't have a marginal problem that
you have a really big serious problem
perhaps you're more bold in the
solutions in Europe the two and a half
years since this process began has been
characterized by too little and too late
and this last delivery was part of that
we got finally yes we know we got a
Greek haircut okay great but that's
that's effective ring-fencing to contain
the crisis to prevent the kinds of
things that have been happening in
Europe in the last 24 hours would have
also meant being more proactive meaning
you really put your best foot forward in
recapitalising the bank so you don't
shortchange the banks so that the run
doesn't spill from Greece to the
European banks which it has and let us
not forget that the restructurings will
not end with Greece if you look at the
debts of Ireland and you look at the
debts of Portugal those debts do not
appear to be sustainable by most
reasonable economic assumptions so I
don't think the restructuring process
will end with Greece Italy's finances
are complicated at this conjunction even
as we waver in this horrid market face I
do think Italy and Spain will still sort
of muddle through I think everybody that
the operative term here is muddled I
don't think this is the end of the world
scenario but in this sequence in which
you go from financial crash to a fiscal
crisis the next stage I believe will
involve our and component a big
component of d globalization in the
financial industry governments are
scrambling to place their debts and who
holds their debts captive domestic
audiences the pension funds the
insurance companies the domestic banks
the emerging markets which have been
largely on the sidelines of the show are
trying to be very leery of allowing too
much hot money seeking the eternal quest
for higher yields
uh into coming across border so capital
controls have flourished with the large
blessing of the IMF what am I saying
where are we in this drama this drama is
not over I don't think the
restructurings in Europe will end with
Greece I think the US will see a
protracted period of subpar economic
activity not all crises manifest
themselves in drama ah but if you are
looking for subpar associated with high
levels of public and private debt look
no further than japan i am not saying
the u.s. is japan it would be stretching
the comparison but i think the the
research that I've done uh points in the
direction of saying very high levels of
public debt are associated with lower
growth and the process of private sector
deleveraging is long and painful and so
the themes that I will leave with you I
will stop here the themes that I will
leave with you are the crisis is not
over the restructurings there are more
restructurings down the road the period
ahead is a not necessarily in my view
the end of the world or catastrophe or
whatever but it is a bleak period uh I
think at best what we can hope is that
the g20 helps foster a dialogue of
recognizing the severity of the problem
there's a lot of denial I was in a panel
with Klaus ringlin uh how you pronounce
his name or did I slaughter it ok well
uh in which my impression after
listening to him in that panel was it
there wasn't a European debt problem
there was a Greek debt problem
so uh and i think looking forward many
of you are interested in various
dimensions of globalization i think
globalization financial globalization is
going to be taking considerable steps
backwards and i let me leave that in
that uplifting well then I don't want to
ask you for the impossible but just let
me say can you say something more
optimistic but maybe it's not raining
sunny if you had held this panel session
last Friday Ernesto I would have been in
in the very unusual position of being
the relative optimist on the panel and
the reason I say that is when you're
dealing with a delusional patient
getting the patient to acknowledge that
he's suffering from delusions it's a
major step forward and the eurozone
leadership has been suffering from what
I consider to beat severe delusions for
a long time and big progress I believe
was made at the end of last week on two
fronts one acknowledging that Greece was
not going to be able to pay its debts
that may seem obvious to all of you
perhaps obvious to to us but the
eurozone leadership was unwilling prior
to last week to acknowledge that and
second that the eurozone banks were
going to have to be recapitalised the
two problems go together intimately the
banks in Europe are deeply exposed to a
sovereign debt they are the main holders
of sovereign debt in Europe and of
course the sovereigns themselves are
very exposed to the weaknesses in the
banks because they've decided to
underwrite all the banks risks you may
remember several years ago when the
crisis hit in Ireland with the banks it
started as a banking crisis not a
government debt crisis the first thing
the Irish government did was say don't
worry we guarantee all the
a debts of the six major Irish banks
crisis is over and of course that simply
spread the crisis from the banks to the
government so I thought the statement at
the end of last week was at least a
significant step forward it was not a
solution by any stretch of the
imagination but it was a formal
recognition of the problem and I think
the fact that the milk markets reacted
as as well as they did at the end of
last week was a an indication that that
was the general perception Europe is
coming to grips with with the problem
today everything is different the
statement by the Greek Prime Minister
which apparently shocked his own finance
minister that he's going to hold a
referendum in January to decide whether
to accept this bailout packages to my
mind inconceivable Greece right now is
at the epicenter of the eurozone crisis
and indeed a potential or world crisis
and it is not possible to run Greece
like an ancient Greek city state or a
swiss canton right now they have to say
yes they have to say thank you and they
have to move on in my view there is no
way no way we get from here until
January without a major crisis unless
the the Greeks back off on this i don't
know how politically one backs off on
this but it is not possible to get from
here until january without a resolution
of the greek problem and that of course
is just one one of the many problems
that we have to deal with i believe in
order for the eurozone leadership to
contain this crisis they have to
quarantine Greece as it work make sure
that this problem doesn't spread beyond
Greece right now in my view the one
institution that can hold the fort as it
were and I'll explain what I mean by
that momentarily is the European Central
Bank and this is not the sort of
institution that one would normally put
forward as a hero it's an unlikely hero
it may be shocking to you hearing a
little bit of recent history now but it
was as recent as februari of last year
when jean-claude trichet oh just stepped
down as president of the ECB said that
it was quote unquote inconceivable that
Greece would go to the IMF not that
Greece would default that was of course
inconceivable but it was even
inconceivable that they would go to the
IMF then of course the ECB would never
buy a European government debt it would
not engage in fiscal policy it did that
then they told us well this is nothing
to do with monetary policy don't worry
we will sterilize all these operations
in other words the money that we we
print to buy the debt we will soak back
up through other means they didn't do
that so it's not a particularly credible
institution right now but politically
it's the only institution right now that
can hold the fort by in particular of
financing the Italian deficits buying
Italian government bonds that are
considerably lower than a market rate
now when I say they have to hold the
fort I want to emphasize that although
many of you may read commentary in the
paper that the ECB should spend one
trillion euros two trillion three
trillion whatever whatever it takes to
to get us through this crisis the ECB
does not have unlimited ammunition the
ECB has a total of eighty 1 billion
euros in capital to put that in
perspective a 25-percent haircut on Pig
debt that's Portugal Ireland Greece I'm
excluding Spain and Italy would be
enough to wipe out that 81 a billion
euros in capital now without getting
into the technicalities of central
banking it is very possible for a
central bank to operate for a period
without capital but the problem is that
the markets are reasonably
forward-looking and someday the european
central bank will have to tighten
monetary policy and the only way to do
that is to have assets to sell so they
will have to be recapitalized and so it
all comes back to germany whether it's
germany underwriting
euro bond so-called euro bonds or
whether it's Germany underwriting the
ECB there is no escaping that at the end
of the day Germany will have to be
willing and able to bear the bill here
and there are limits to what the the
German a public are willing to bear I
think the leadership is is trying as
cautiously as possible to explain to the
German public that it's in their
interest their own financial interest
long-term political interest of the
country to step forward here and play
the dominant role but that's a difficult
message to put forth particularly given
developments today that is the Greek
saying we're not sure we like this deal
we're going to ask our publics in
January and then we'll get back to you
thank you very much that really in my
view is is wholly untenable now many in
Europe would like to believe that China
could represent a potential component of
the solution to this problem well it's
it's clear why there's such enthusiasm
for China participating if you look at
china's net euro purchases last year
they are equivalent to the entire 2012
financing needs of all the pigs nations
portugal ireland italy green and greece
and spain all of them put together so if
china wanted to play a major role here
it certainly could but i think we have a
tendency in the United States and in
Europe to view the Chinese government is
a completely monolithic entity that's
completely apart from public opinion in
China because it's not a democracy but
the Chinese government has to be
responsive to a public opinion the
stability of the the government relies
on that and it would be extraordinarily
difficult for the Chinese government to
be able to explain to the people why
they would be bailing out rich Europeans
when there's still so much poverty
in hardship within a China though
politically i do not see China is be
part of the solution it's difficult to
talk much about the United States right
now but I would like to talk about the
United States maybe you can give us a
good news there but I'm sure President
President Obama welcomes having some of
the spotlight taken off him at least for
the moment but it's going to be right
back on in a few weeks time many of you
may remember from the whole debt crisis
that captivated the world over the
summer that there is a deficit super
commission that is supposed to tell us
by Thanksgiving what the 1.5 trillion
dollars in debt reduction is going to be
comprised of and if they can't tell us
that then there's going to be an
automatic chopping of 1.2 trillion
dollars from discretionary spending 500
billion of that will will come out of
defense i find it inconceivable that
this commission of 12 angry men and
women with no Henry Fonda in the room to
talk sense to them could possibly come
up with a solution this dramatic over
the next three weeks that does mean that
these automatic cuts are going to kick
in but I have little doubt that Congress
will reverse them over the next several
years these these are this is called
discretionary spending because it's
discretionary Congress can add its
discretion reinstate all of it next year
if they choose to do so so I think the
US is going to be back in the in the
spotlight it Steve you are my last hope
I am now with very little hope well I
hate to let you down Ernesto
I'm very optimistic on China maybe I
should stop there but first of all thank
you for setting up this event in a
rather timely fashion brilliantly so I
might add and I give you credit for that
just want to pick up on something that
that Carmen very eloquently said in her
opening statement when she talked about
denial of biblical proportions he the
only area that I might differ with her
on is that I would say that this denial
is truly global in scope the Europeans
you know certainly have their strain of
it but it's something deeply rooted in
our culture and was very much part of
the the blunders that were made by Japan
in the late 80s and throughout the 1990s
who somehow we just don't want to admit
when we've got it wrong the record of
the world in avoiding and dealing with
crises over the last three decades is
terrible i'm looking at a list here of
eleven crises in the past 30 years
starting with the latin debt crisis of
the early eighties stock market crash of
1987 us S&L crisis 1990 japan 1990
mexico sorry ernesto in 1995 an expert
for their own recent asian financial
crisis 97 98 ltcm and 98 dot-com bubble
in two thousand accounting scandals in
2001 subprime in 2007 in Europe now I
mean it's you know a crisis every three
years
they get bigger they get more global and
scope and we really don't have a much of
a clue as to how to avoid them let alone
deal with them g20 great idea I agree
with you too bad it's not working these
g20 summits have become more of an event
planning exercise than something of
substance in really i think grappling
with the tough issues that the world
economy needs to address i just want to
deal with three aspects of this policy
debate that I think need to be put on
the table in trying to assess where
we're headed number one I think were and
this is contentious especially at Yale
when we had a internal summit with some
of the great minds of Yale a few weeks
ago and trying to solve the US jobs
problem the consensus of that group was
that we had the right policies we just
didn't have enough of them my take is
that that view is wrong that blunt
stabilization policies just are not
working to resuscitate crisis torn
economies that's true of traditional
Keynesian fiscal policies as well as
these creative unconventional monetary
policies it's not a question of degree
it's just a question of whether or not
these policies are able to achieve
traction in ending balance sheet
recessions 20 plus years later in Japan
it's clear that these policies don't
work and I would say a few years into
our Japanese like balance sheet
recession
and as aftermath in the u.s. these
policies aren't working as well the
second point I want to make is a
corollary to this and that is that it is
increasingly evident that targeted
policies aimed at balance sheet repair
stand a much better chance of working
for example the so-called congestion of
corporate zombies the economic Walking
Dead started to work pretty well in
Japan once the restructuring of Japanese
companies began in earnest in the late
and 19 and 90s and I think that's
there's an important lesson there
especially for the United States in as
much as we now have a large generation
of zombie consumers that need help in
dealing with the problems that
critically ale their balance sheets and
i would say policies of debt forgiveness
and creative saving incentives would go
a long way in fixing and accelerating
the balance sheet repair in the u.s. in
europe you've already talked about the
zombies they're mainly government
officials and policy makers who continue
to duck the biggest elephant in the room
that was underscored by the point
already made today very eloquently by
ben and that is that you know Europe can
talk about the single currency the
single central bank till they're blue in
the face but there's no fiscal or
political union until that leg gets put
into the stool the stool is is is very
much in danger of tipping over and I
guess the the final point I want to just
throw it in and you know inject into
this discussion or Ernesto is that these
this list of policies increasingly
global in scope is is is critically
important especially in the context of
that very provocative and depressing
point that Carmen left us with the risk
of financial d globalization I really
share that and it's it's a huge worry of
mine and it really demands that groups
like the g20 true who are empowered
politically to to deal with global
issues are it's really incumbent upon
them to think much more deeply about a
robust global policy architecture and
they talk the talk and his Carmen said
they're not walking the walk or I guess
that was you Ernesto you might have said
a to Carmen but in what needs to be done
there they've they've talked about it in
terms of multilateral surveillance
developing early warning metrics but
they refuse to really tackle the
toughest piece of that which is an
enforcement mechanism what happens if
company if countries violate these
various rules that jeopardize the global
economy are there consequences of that I
think their monies to be much greater
focus on the issue of financial
stability we pay lip service to that but
we don't do it the Chinese there's a you
know a model of economic management that
we can I think take lessons from in
their fixation on stability financial
economic and social stability and
finally I think we're in continue to be
in denial of biblical proportions to
steal your word of the the perils of
global imbalances the fact that
countries get away forever with running
savings deficits current account
deficits or or the same is true of the
surpluses and the
if you add up all the current account
surpluses and deficits in the world
today irrespective of sign they peaked
at at about six percent of GDP I think
pre-crisis in 2006 which is about six
times what they were ten years earlier
they're narrower now but probably just
temporarily because of business cycle
conditions we are deluding ourselves
into believing that we can live in a
world with sustained global imbalances
so this is a you know I won't say it's
the 11th hour but you know the clock is
ticking and the stakes are getting
bigger and I think Monsieur Sarkozy was
feeling really very happy has been put
it late last week he was going to go
into this the summoning can with with
great momentum and now III don't think
he even wants to show up at this summit
and the g20 is clueless once again well
thank you for cheating us up and let's
have some interchange and let me take on
something that Carmen sets you said well
she said something like that okay
blanton that they had the right
diagnosis and they knew what the
solutions were I don't think that would
have made a big difference that was your
a statement and this of course is derive
in a way from your impressive historical
statistic analysis of previous crisis as
well as yer analytics of the of the
present situation
but let me just for the sake of
excitement try to challenge that idea
with a mental exercise and simply assume
that the key g20 countries had tried
harder to do what they say they would do
early on in the crisis of course what
they did early on in the crisis were
relatively easy to do but there was a
different stage that demanded the
adoption of policies that we knew were
politically very difficult to adopt but
they were necessary and the question
where was whether they did all what was
within their capacity to execute those
policies domestic policies and the
second question is what would have
happened they had deliver the kind of
international coordination and
cooperation that they depicted i would
say for good reason as indispensable in
order to minimize the cost of adjustment
that we have to go through rather than
being trapped in this order prison of
mercantilism in which we are today in
which is the prisoner's dilemma and that
could have the best possible outcome
because they truly refuse to empower a
third party to put on the table in a
very transparent way what was the
respective responsibilities of each of
the major economies to get out of this
mess and instead the US has moved in one
direction China continues to move in its
own direction we have a spoken about
your
so my challenge my very modest challenge
is in the sense that things should not
be as they are today haven't we learned
from history and I think we have learned
from history because there have been so
many shops even some of those that were
mentioned by Steve that could cut cut
much worse outcomes and they didn't have
those Hopkins because we had learned
something from history and probably the
crisis in 08 09 will be today a
depression if we hadn't extracted a few
lessons from the traumatic episodes of
the 1930s so we did learn some things or
we learned a lot but somehow political
systems have been unable to deliver the
necessary policies so that would be my
little challenge I don't think that it
is determined in a fatal fatal way that
things should be as they are today I
think we have to put a lot of
responsibility and I will say almost
blame on political leaders about the
situation we are now in but I don't know
if my colleagues want to have a reaction
Carmen well I stick to my view surprised
it did hear me uh I've been studying
crisis for 20 years and I have tried to
convince European leaders unsuccessfully
that the European crisis bears indeed
many resemblances to emerging market
crisis from beginning to end it is just
happening in a different region of the
world that we had become unaccustomed to
having such crises since the 1930s so
there is a very close
post mind to learn and part of the g20
group is emerging markets that dare they
say that this crisis is a lot like an
emerging market crisis sure they should
dare say that but will it be heated I
don't I so I have no confidence that
even if they were to diagnose it
properly and make the proper suggestions
two years ago it seems absurd now there
was this great debate about Greece it's
not going to get an IMF program you know
Greece at the IMF god forbid now it is
also the case that we have conveniently
forgotten that advanced economies where
the primary users of the IMF up until
the early 1980s that Britain had the UK
had 11 IMF programs those things seem to
be forgotten so we either forget things
about our own past or we pretend that
the things that happened to you somehow
happened to you because you're not like
me I'm summarizing what I believe is a
fundamental problem with human nature
which is why I crises keep happening and
have they have we learned we have
learned in a limited way I would put a
capital letter unlimited because the
essence of this time is different is
that all those leverage ratios we don't
really have to worry about those
leverage ratios because after all we're
dealing with you instruments after all
we are advanced economies after all this
time is different and when it comes to
crisis resolution it's the same I mean
the the very early on I'm not saying
this as a sort of very early on Ken
Rogoff and I were out there saying in in
2008 debts are going to have to
restructured that you know restructuring
was part of the answer was not a pretty
answer but it's part of the answer um
and even very recently there was
complete denial and I just want to go to
something been said on the denial issue
and I see things been it's the same way
as you do this is ultimately the central
banks are going to have to play a big
role here and whether we like it or not
a lot of the Dead has has to be
monetized a lot of this is just too big
and onerous however the denial at which
the ECB at least in language if not in
actions because they're buying Italian
bonds as we speak right left and center
uh is is massive and again I think you
know we're very Ernesto I I think we
learned some things to make sure that
the crisis wasn't as bad as the 1930s so
it wasn't as deep as the 1930s but it
may very well be as long as the Japanese
one because we're not out of this woods
yet so I'm just very skeptical yeah can
i just pick up on that just for a second
i think you're correct to ernesto to you
know congratulate policymakers for being
good at stopping a crisis and and it's
debatable as to whether or not that's a
lesson from the 30s or from other
episodes but you know i'll grant that
that's the case so they've learned that
when markets are dysfunctional and
freefall and sentiment is collapsing to
marshal all the firepower they can
especially central banks and flood the
system with liquidity and stop the
crisis but stopping the crisis is one
thing and sustaining a recovery is
another and they haven't figured out how
to do that no matter what you say and
moreover
I would argue that because of the
severity of this rolling three years of
crisis and it goes back further than
that we've now got policy instruments
locked down into zones with zero
interest rates and double-digit budget
deficits that they can't get out of
every time I mean young again study
Japan you know every time they try to
move out of zero interest rates you know
the system rolls over again and then we
have this debate over austerity on
fiscal policy and I would argue that
this policy can under more in leaving
our key monitoring fiscal instruments at
extreme levels by any standard of the
imagination sets us up for more of the
same nobody can predict with great
precision the next crisis although
Carmen to her credit laid out a very
provocative I guess stage three but I
think we're just asking for trouble
until we crack the code of of moving out
of the crisis response mindset into
trying to figure out how in God's name
we can ever foster a sustainable
post-crisis recovery that's enormous
challenge right now but there were two
ideas one was the balance sheet repair
and the other is addressing seriously
systemically structurally the problem of
global imbalances and if i go back to
many statements that have been made i
would say there is no lack of awareness
from the part to policymakers that this
kind of issues must be addressed and
then the question is why they don't do
it I mean it's not because they are
silly but there must be something about
lyrical systems a capacity to to trigger
or to use the right instruments to
address this kind of problems and that I
think somehow take us back to the the
core of our profession you know when was
it that we forgot that economics was
about human beings and solving real life
issues that our classics used to call
our discipline political economy and
therefore we were supposed to understand
not only economic models but also to
understand politics and therefore my my
question provocative deven I mean did
you see political systems to evolve into
I think you're you're Ernesto you're
almost being too kind to the political
leadership in Europe and the United
States by suggesting that it's just a
matter of systemic incapacity let me
take up your invitation earlier to refer
to economic history to give an example
in the 1940s the United States was
absolutely dominant in the global
economy in terms of our net creditor
position we were beyond where China is
right now what position did we take in
the first half of the 1940s with regard
to global imbalances American foreign
economic policy was run at that time by
a narrow minded bullheaded individual
named harry dexter white who was
convinced that this was an opportunity
for the United States to change the
world by forcing liquidation of the
British Empire and building up and do
alliance with the Soviet Union he was it
turned out a part-time Soviet agent and
he was absolutely determined at Bretton
Woods to make sure that other countries
could not have any impact on the United
States net creditor position he was
determined that the United States would
be able to maintain it and what happened
right after the war Britain collapse it
caused costs a political calamity for
the United States Dean Acheson who
eventually became Secretary of State
said my god while he watched Greece
collapse Greece was collapsing because
the the British were pulling out all
their troops because they couldn't
afford to pay them anymore he said my
god there are only two powers left in
the world the United States and the
Soviet Union we have to do something now
and the United States changed policy
entirely instead of a foreign economic
policy being driven by harry dexter
white was now driven by general Marshall
became Secretary of State and his
economic brain a man named will clayton
who have a Norma's admiration for who
who remade American foreign economic
policy and one of the the first things
they did in order to rectify the the
collapse in New in Europe was the
Marshall Plan which is something harry
dexter white could never have conceived
them but it made an enormous difference
there was a vast dollar shortage in
europe which was collapsing the entire a
global economy and the united states
took a farsighted approach at the time
they would not let that happen they
would help Europe rebuild they would
force European integration in fact in
many ways it was the united states that
built the foundations of the the
european union so political leadership
actually does matter individuals in
power can have enormous influence it's
not just well the system won't let us
the the actual people in power do make a
difference people like Sarkozy and
Merkel and Papa Papa and rail they could
make a enormous difference they could do
things differently